l'heure est aux vendanges élan courtoise
les amis du passé d'elancourt prépare la
récolte prévue ce dimanche 2 octobre
elle rassemblera les élans courtois
autour des vignes de la ferme du
mousseau notamment avec la participation
des enfants de l'école maternelle du
berceau ils vont fouler égrappé prêcher
boire du jus de raisin et ils auront
droit bien un petit goûter offert par
les amis du passé bien mérité pour
l'association c'est le moment de
partager les connaissances et les
difficultés de la pratique viticole il
faut entretenir les disons les branches
enlever les grandes feuilles et veiller
à ce que justement les grappes qui sont
en train de pousser ne tombe pas sur le
coût de la maladie et donc il faut
traiter comme dans toute la france avec
le mauvais temps il ya eu beaucoup de
maladies beaucoup de grappes qui sont
malades regarder certaines sont très
mûrs et par contre dont certaines sont
encore à peine à l'état vert avec son
vin rosé le clos mousseau et l'encours
est partagé entre modernité et ruralité
nous avons des vignals en cours depuis
le haut moyen âge et donc nous
continuons à perpétuer cette tradition
ça c'est pour s'inscrire dans la
tradition de la commune ensuite c'est
bien entendu symbolique est important
parce que la vigne le raisin le jus de
raisin c'est la sève de la terre c'est
ce qui rapproche l'histoire des longs
cours et de ses paysans de la vie
moderne d'aujourd'hui
rendez vous ce dimanche 2 octobre à la
ferme du mousseau à partir de 10h pour
ramasser le raisin et boire le vin élan
courtois avec modération